and then i met brian pumper at the 24
hour fitness oh were you disappointed i
was like what the [__] are you doing he
was in there recruiting
bro what year did you meet brian plumber
uh let's see
i'll say 2011-12 or something like that
that's when he came with the
oh that was like peak peak pumper that
was when he was [__]
turning out lawrence fishburne's
daughter oh yeah i forgot about that
yeah you know he
she had a pimply butt yep hey a couple
of times i loved
her video with that white guy in the car
um but it was
uh hey um so brian pumper when i met him
he was beefing with fab on twitter yeah
remember that he's because fabulous is
called
calling brian pumper jules yeah i was
like and he was a big dude i was like
hey bro you think you're going
and he was trying to rap he was trying
to rap and that's why i was like he was
like bro this one this is so funny our
conversation i was like bro you got fam
you're not like the hype people yeah of
course i believe in you he was like
don't worry
wait till the disc coming soon i said
don't do it please just just all you got
to do is keep [__]
all you got to do to win the diss is
just [__] a girl that looked like his
his baby mom or somebody and be like
yeah and wear throat
and wear a paper towel headband or
something like a backwards jersey and a
[__]
5x mitchell in there yeah it'd just be
like yeah just just sitting
like oh this dick feel like street
dreams
yo i met brian pumper at um i was out of
north me and my wife were at this uh
boba place
in north hollywood and uh we're just
getting
donuts i think or something okay okay
and he walked in
and i was like i told my wife i said
yeah that's brian pumper
who the [__] is that i said he's a porn
star and that was when my wife realized
how much of a piece of [__] i was
because she was like wait you know
that's a man you know his name i was
like you don't understand it's like a
he's like popping for show so i was like
hey man what's up brian pumper was
popping man you're a legend you know
what i'm saying
i swear to god this [__] left
the boba place and got into like a 1999
[__] toyota sentra that was filled
filled with all of his belongings and
looked like it hadn't been washed in
like seven since it came out
it was insane bro he got into this [__]
it was like the most beat down car you
will ever see someone get into
and it was filled the passenger seat the
back seat
every single piece of space in that car
had some [__] in it
i swear to [__] god bro so the jury
is fake
of course and he still had to the crazy
thing is he had a chain on him
you died by that and he got in that car
and i was like oh
brian pumper down bad bro you believe in
that bro
the thing about it yo that chain is real
okay it's about you got to be hood rich
okay you get a lot of people i was like
[__] obviously he got in that car is
none of your goddamn business he jumped
in there central with all his [__] like
hey man hell yeah mario goddamn [__]
you know what i'll do i could be moving
in the process of moving
i'm homeless brian pumper yeah that's
crazy yeah i was like i was like uh
that's crazy because i do know a bunch
of male porn stars names though oh you
do oh bro wesley pipes is my god
yeah i don't know back in the day was
like shawn michaels
uh shawn michaels was popping uh not the
wrestler no there was a guy named sean
michaels
black dude [__] you know swain i mean
obviously like peter north is a p
peter north og what was the other dude i
met i've met all these guys at the avn's
bro me and adam still lexington steel
yes
i i just want you to keep guessing
throwing dudes names out bro me and
i was at the uh we're at the porn
pornhub award thingies
and i was at the bar with uh my friend
adam and uh
one of the guys from black.com was
getting a drink next to us
and i was like yo is it gay if i say
like hey bro like
i see you bro like you you doing your
thing bro like i'm
like i'm a fan like you know dude what
if you did geek out
no no no i was just i was just like hey
what's up bro i watch your [__] you know
what i'm saying like
that's kind of that's weird as [__]
isn't that weird like hey bro you got
you got a great your dick is huge
yeah i see you bro black.com that's all
you right there
you you you being black oh man